jeder kennt das wenn er irgendwo auf dem
Klo sitzt und dann eine von zwei Sachen
passiert entweder die Klopapierrolle ist
falsch rum so dass das Papier an der
Wand hängt und man soll nicht richtig
runterziehen kann oder noch schlimmer
hängt einfach eine leere Rolle weil
wieder irgend jemand zu faul oder die
nachfüllen und nicht selten bin das
einfach ich
diese Probleme gerne mal weiter
Vergangenheit anwenden ich hatte die
Idee vom Smart klorollenhalter ich meine
alles ist mittlerweile Smart Handy ist
Fernseher Kühlschränke und selbst ein
Toaster ist mittlerweile einfach
schlauer als du selbst und hat Internet
Zugriff und genau das machen wir jetzt
auch dem ach so simplen klorollenhalter
einfach ein Motor und Internet Zugriff
spendieren damit der das Klopapier
automatisch richtig rum dreht
automatisch leere Rollen einfach in den
Mülleimer wird und dann so langsam
extrem lauter
89 der Traum von jedem der Mitbewohner
hat oder von jedem der sich zur dritten
Werkstatt hat unendlich aussehen will
wäre das immer ist der die Rolle nicht
nachfüllt wahrscheinlich dürfte die alte
Rolle selber nie weg
dieses Video wird unterstützt von
milanout mehr dazu später ich bauen
Smart klorollenhalter der die Rollen
automatisch richtig rum dreht die leere
Rolle automatisch abwirft und Alarm
schlägt wenn die Rolle nicht aufgefüllt
wird
eigentlich muss ich
dir das bestellen was heißt für dich
richtig rum schon so wie ich immer oder
doch
aber wie setzen wir das ganze jetzt um
ursprünglich wollte ich so machen dass
die Rolle die jetzt hier falsch rum
drauf ist dann einfach so gedreht wird
ja aber dass er mega umständlich gewesen
und dann hatte Pascal die Idee die
Klopapierrolle einfach so zu drehen und
dann fällt das automatisch auch genauso
hin das ist richtig rum ist die Stange
hier ist also eine Motor befestigt und
wenn die Rolle irgendwann leer ist macht
der hier den hier und dann fällt dir
runter in Papier und um die Handy-App
können wir uns später jetzt geht aber
erstmal ums Design äh Manu kannst du das
kontrollieren so mache ich also ein
klorollenhalter braucht unbedingt
wireless charging also erstmal eine
Schale fürs Handy kontrollieren für die
ganze Technik die daran sollten großen
hässlichen Kasten über den sich Thomas
bestimmt richtig freuen wird und dann
noch ein paar Aussparungen für
Servomotor und die wegezelle und das
Klopapier muss auch noch irgendwo drauf
also gibt's auch noch einen Halter
hierfür und ab in den 3D Drucker damit
[Musik]
gedacht hat das ist der Körper da kommt
einmal die Elektronik rein ja jetzt
verstehe ich hier kommt der Servomotor
rein
jetzt soll das dran dafür gibt's das
hier let's go jetzt wird der immer drauf
gesteckt
und kann sich dann hier
eben um den Motor drehen also auf das
Ding hier soll ja offensichtlich die
Klopapierrolle drauf das wird dann
wahrscheinlich so sein doch eine
Abdeckung drauf und fertig ist der
kloreinhalter aber ist natürlich aktuell
noch sau dumm und kann gar nichts das
erste was er können soll ist das richtig
laut piepst wenn in irgendjemand leer
lässt damit derjenige direkt entlarvt
wird und darum kümmert sich jetzt Pascal
[Musik]
so in dem Teil jetzt eine äußerst
sinnvolle Aufgabe beizubringen noch ein
Gehirn in dem Fall ein esp32 der auch
Beifahrer hat an den werden dann die
verschiedenen Zensoren angeschlossen
einmal die wegezelle die wiegt wie viel
Klopapier noch da ist und einmal der
Infrarotsensor der erkennt wenn das
Klopapier falsch rum ist und wenn ihr
meinen Platz zu nahe kommt und dann dem
Servomotor sagt dass er sich und damit
die Rolle andersrum drehen soll sobald
die Wege Zelt zu wenig Gewicht misst
weil die Rolle leer ist wird im
Servomotor gesagt er soll sich so
umdrehen dass die Rolle runterfällt
jetzt noch ein kleines Display als
Anzeige wie viel Klopapier immer noch
auf der Rolle hat sowie den nervigsten
Piepser den ich finden konnte zum
Schluss noch eine Antenne dran klipsen
für die Verbindung zum Netzwerk und
fertig das Display rein
und zeigt da jetzt einfach live den
Füllstand an oder halt das Gewicht von
der Rolle und wenn ich da jetzt einfach
mal eine deutlich höhere Rolle
draufsetzt
geht es direkt nur auf die Hälfte der
Ladung und wenn ich diese Rolle dann
jetzt weg mache ja noch wichtiger
dann ist das das nervigste Geräusch
dieser Erde und das halt so lang bis man
dann eine neue volle rolle drauf macht
wichtig wichtige Funktion kann man
nichts anderes sagen noch wichtiger ist
dass man das nicht mehr über das Display
sehen kann sondern dass ich den
Füllstand jetzt hier auch auf dem Handy
sehe und ja ich sehe da quasi in
Echtzeit wie der Klopapier verbraucht
wird wir vielleicht merkt dass die
Planung von diesem Projekt schon
ziemlich komplex für den smart
klopapierrollenhalter haben wir das
Ganze also um organisiert zu bleiben in
Milano geplant den sponsert das heutige
Videos ist kostenlos und vom Prinzip her
wie ein digitales Whiteboard auf dass
ihr alles an Inspirationen Ideen und
Informationen draufschmeißen könnt um
alles an einem Ort zusammen und eure
Gedanken zu strukturieren bei diesem
Projekt habe ich angefangen mit einer
Beschreibung vom Projekt und dann ein
moodboard gemacht mit
inspirationsbildern ich mit den Bildern
und Web Clipper einfach von überall aus
dem Internet direkt in meinen moodboard
geschickt haben ich habe dann mehrere
Tours zum Abhaken erstellt damit jeder
im Team direkt weiß was als Nächstes
gemacht werden muss und dort auch eine
Gruppe Skizze vom klopapierrollenhalter
gekritzelt genauso wie bei Ordnern am
Computer kann man in jedem Wort einfach
erstellen die euch hier oben angezeigt
werden im Bauteile unter Bord hat Pascal
die ganzen Links zu den
Elektronikbauteilen zu der Einkaufsliste
zusammengefügt der kann nämlich von
seinem Laptop aus aber natürlich auch
vom Handy in Echtzeit aufs gleichen
millernote Board zugreifen weil ich das
mit ihm einfach über einen
Einladungslink geteilt habe millernote
ist komplett kostenlos also klickt auf
den Link in der Videobeschreibung und
probiert melanout aus egal ob ihr ein
Bauprojekt eine Startup Idee eure neue
Inneneinrichtung oder den nächsten
Urlaub planen wollte und wenn der leer
ist ja soll er nicht nur Piepsen sondern
auch den hier drehen dass die Rolle hier
runterfällt dafür wird einfach der
Servomotor an dem die Rolle aufgehangen
ist per Code um 90 Grad gedreht sobald
die Decke Zelle 0 Gramm Klopapier ist
und wenn ich das jetzt leer macht
ja dann will ich jetzt erstmal nichts
messen welcher auch dran anzieht
aber jetzt ist es leer jetzt denkt er
sich so Bruder es ist leer und jetzt
zumindest in der Theorie
wird das abgeworfen mega geil das Ultra
krass und jetzt gibt's halt immer noch
also will Bruder fühl mich nach und dann
habe ich hier so die volle Rolle
das ist mega geil und das Piepsen nervt
halt komplett das ist halt echt so geil
dass ich gleich nochmal machen will ne
ich mache jetzt die Rolle hier ab machen
meine Lehre drauf damit ich sie nicht
verschwenden muss der Bruder ist es
einfach leer Film nicht nach bestraft
mich einfach damit dass ich jetzt hier
zuhören muss und jetzt dann erst ab
und piept dann einfach wieder ist so
geil sehr geil das ist wirklich einfach
revolutionär aber was ist und Gott
bewahre wenn jetzt jemand das Klopapier
hier falsch rum drauf macht das soll
sich dann eigentlich auch so drehen das
ist eben doch wieder richtig rum ist
aber wie soll das Teil hier erkennen wie
rum die Rolle hier gedreht ist wir
verwenden dafür sondern Infrarotsensor
der die Entfernung ist und wenn ihm ein
Objekt zu nahe kommt sendet der ein
Signal unser Code reagiert auf dieses
Signal und sagt den Server Mutter dann
dass er sich um 180 Grad drehen soll
bevor ich das Ding aber jetzt an die
Bart rein Schraube und wir testen ob das
auch wirklich funktioniert verpasse ich
den Gerät noch wireless charging klar
keine ordentliche Smart Klopapierrollen
Haltevorrichtung ohne wireless Charger
versteht sich von selbst dann wäre noch
die ganze Elektronik irgendwie im
Gehäuse verbrachtet und da kommt der
Deckel drauf so vollkommener
Funktionstest jetzt wir haben eine fast
leere Rolle und die machen wir jetzt mal
leer
[Musik]
happy extrem nervig das macht schon mal
währenddessen die neue ready der wird
die andere ab ich lege die jetzt drauf
Alter der ist richtig schnell
drauf zu machen
Alter holy Shit das ist vor allem der
instant bestrafungseffekt das ist nicht
so als ob man das ran macht und er dreht
danach 10 Sekunden oder so sondern
kein Smart Gadget ohne Wilding drauf
und es lädt es ist richtig geil ja cool
also ich finde es richtig notwendig
essentiell wenn ihr das auch dein Glas
mit dem tun mit dem wir das geplant
haben aber ihr auch eure Urlaub oder
sonst das planen könnt findet ihr in der
Videobeschreibung und ich bin damit raus